[Music]
are you guys ready agency fees which are
the fees non-members are forced to pay
unions for representation in some states
and the Abood precedent that allows them
could both be scrapped when the Supreme
Court hears Janus versus asked me so why
the fight over agency fees unions call
these fees fair share fees because
everybody covered by a union negotiated
contract has to pay for representation
the fees are typically two-thirds of
full membership dues and they aren't
supposed to support unions political
activities balancing freedom of
expression with the need to prevent Free
Riders the petitioner Janus argues that
agency fees infringe on freedoms of
speech and Association claiming it's
impossible to separate unions political
and non-political functions when union
bargaining with the government is
inherently political for Janus it's not
about the money it's about compelled
speech starry decisis is a legal
principle that makes overturning
precedents rare but many court watchers
including unions expect the conservative
justices will overturn a booth whether
the court decides agency fees are an
appropriate balance or compelled speech
will have a major influence on the
future of America's unions for more on
Janus agency fees and why they are so
important for teachers union membership
check the links in the description below
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI